this is a production of cornell
university
hello my name is larry smart i'm a
professor in the horticulture section of
the school of integrated plant science
and i'm based at cornell agritech in
geneva
i've been at cornell for 12 years now
previously i was a professor at the suny
college of environmental science and
forestry in syracuse
where i started studying shrub willow as
a bioenergy crop
so let's talk a little bit about
some of the urgent needs in society that
we can address with agriculture the most
urgent is to address climate change and
to reduce the amount of carbon and other
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
shrub willow can address that issue
because it can be used as a source of
liquid biofuels
which to be honest are being replaced by
electric vehicles at this point
it can be used as a source of electric
power
by burning wood chips in power plants
which
again as we switch to electrification of
our automobiles
can
serve as a carbon neutral fuel source
for electrification
we can also use wood chips as a source
of heating fuel and we do that here at
cornell agritech
using willow that we grow on our farms
burned in a boiler that heats two of our
buildings just a mile away from where
the willow was grown
so local energy
we're also looking at willow for other
ecosystem services
willow can be planted in riparian buffer
zones to take up nutrients and protect
the water quality in our lakes and
watersheds
we're also looking at a dual purpose for
willow in that respect
in harvesting it or
growing it as a fodder crop
for small ruminants sheep and goats and
we see increasing production of sheep
and goats in new york right now
so those are the end uses
again right now
a push for biofuels in our breeding
program
inspired us to look at biomass
composition and we did a lot of work
to quantify the cellulose lignin and
hemicellulose in willow to try to
optimize it for conversion to biofuels
that era seems to be fading away
so really our main objective
in bioenergy crop breeding right now is
yield and sustainable yield but also
carbon sequestration
so can we also identify willows that
sequester carbon in their root systems
and making the entire system carbon
negative
coupled with that if we can look at high
nitrogen uptake
which will have the dual purpose of
enhancing
nutrient management and protecting our
water quality while also providing a
high quality
feed for sheep and goats
we get additional ecosystem services and
value for the farmer
so those are some of our goals in our
long-term breeding program
we work with many different species of
willow and many of them can hybridize
so
we have focused on topics of hybrid
vigor
many of our species have different
ploidy levels so we actually make
crosses between tetraploid and diploid
species and have done a lot of work to
characterize heterosis in triploid
species hybrids
and we do see consistent
heterosis
in our triploids which also have the
advantage of being sterile
which reduces their potential for
invasiveness
we have used multiple different trait
mapping approaches
to study willow genetics and to identify
markers
for marker assisted selection
although to date we have not been using
a lot of marker assisted selection in
our willow program we are very close to
identifying some of the major genes that
will be important for long-term genetic
improvement
through these different mapping
approaches
so we have used association mapping
or g-wasps
we have generated an f2 mapping
population of salex purpuria
and that is our reference species
we have worked with
the department of energy joint genome
institute to develop very high quality
pac-bio genome assemblies of a male and
female willow i should have mentioned
willow is dioecious
so making these crosses involves
crossing between a male and a female
sibling in a population
we
have also most recently developed
a series of f1 species hybrid mapping
populations
by crossing different diploid species
relatives to our reference species sale
of purpuria
and we believe that will be very
fruitful in the long run
for introducing unique alleles from
these other diverse species
we're particularly interested in
resistance to
rust rust is our major pathogen threat
to willow
and some of these related species to
salix purpuria
bring resistance to our common rust
species here in the united states
so this is the latest
trial that we have planted this past
spring
for genetic mapping it includes about
425
individuals in our s2 mapping population
derived from our monitors individual as
well as another about 180 diverse
unrelated individuals
for
g wasp mapping or association mapping we
plant in three plant plots in a complete
randomized block design
in single rows
so it's relatively easy to cut back
with our tractor mounted single row
harvester and again the goal would be to
identify genes for rust resistance
for resistance to
insect pests
and
to identify variation in other
morphological traits which will lead to
yield increases
so you're probably not accustomed to
growing willow as an agricultural crop
what you see behind me are plants
that
are in their second growing season after
cutback
so this is a short rotation copper
system where we originally plant from
cuttings so our breeding program is
aimed at producing clonal cultivars
propagated through stem cuttings which
we produce in nursery beds
those cuttings can be planted
mechanically
with a planter that will take long whips
and cut on the fly into
eight inch cuttings which it plants in
the ground
we typically will plant in a double row
spacing 30 inches between those rows
two feet between plants which has been
optimized for harvesting with a
self-propelled forage harvester with
large saw blades on the front
so
after original establishment by cuttings
we typically will cut back the field or
composite that stimulates rapid regrowth
of multiple small diameter stems in year
two
and then we will typically allow those
plants to grow three or four years
before we come in with the forage
harvester
to cut them back down to the ground uh
as low as we can get producing wood
chips
that again we deliver to a power plant
uh or to a conversion facility
the plants will vigorously
re-sprout the following spring after
that harvest and we can
continue and sustain that cycle of three
to four year harvest cycles for at least
seven to ten
times meaning that the crop is sustained
and continues to sequester carbon
for 25 to 30 years
so these willow crops
need to
have durable disease resistance for more
than 25 or 30 years
making that one of our most urgent
breeding needs is to identify primarily
rust resistance but also resistance to
insect pests
which will become
more persistent with more life cycles
as
temperatures begin to increase
through climate change
finally we have been looking at sex
determination and the mechanism of the
sex chromosome in salix especially as it
relates to poplar and the evolution of
sex determination in the cellar casey
very interestingly there are different
mechanisms for sex determination across
the kc
either x y
or z w z w being
where the female is the heterogametic
sex
as it is in birds and reptiles
so we have flip-flopping of the sex
determination system across the sala
casey and also movement of the sex
determination region from different
chromosomes in the species that we work
with the sex determination is on
chromosome 15
but in other species of celix it has
moved to chromosome 7
and in poplar it can be found on
chromosome 19.
so those are interesting topics of uh
what is the evolutionary driver for
daishi in the saleh casey and what is
the driver for
zw versus xy
and the movement of the sex
determination region
uh across different chromosomes
is the sex determination region linked
to
genes that are driving
sex dimorphism for example so we've been
doing a lot of research looking at sex
dimorphic traits most recently
the final tool that we have to address
that question is we do find monicious
varieties of willow
so individuals that produce both male
and female flowers on a single
individual
we have used that to create an s1 and
now an s2 mapping population
which we have genotyped and have
recently planted
here for phenotyping so that will give
us yet another
mapping tool to identify important
traits in salex purpuria
in the s2 and we also expect to be able
to identify loci that are responsible
for inbreeding depression in that
population
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu